قتلت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شابا
الفلسطينيا وجرحت اخر خلال اقتحامها لمخيم
عسكر القديم شرق مدينه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه فجر اليوم واكدت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان الشهيد هو صالح صبرا وقد
قتله جنود الاحتلال عندما فتحوا النار على
مجموعه من المواطنين الذين تصدوا لهم حيث
اصيب بعيار ناري قاتل في الصدر كما اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال حي المساكن الشعبيه في
نابلس المجاور للمخيم وكانت المواجهات وقد
اندلعت عند مدخل مخيم عسكر القديم عندما
اقتحمته قوه كبيره من قوات الاحتلال وقامت
بمسح هندسي لمنزل الشهيد عبد الفتاح خريوش
منفذ عمليه حواره قبل نحو شهرين وذلك
تمهيدا لهدمه
كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح
اليوم مخيم طولكرم بالضفه الغربيه اعتقلت
اسيرا محررا بحسب وكاله الانباء
الفلسطينيه وبفت وسالوا من محليه مشاهد
تظهر جانبا من اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للمخيم ومن جهه اخرى قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان قواتها اعتقلت السبعه
فلسطينيين من انحاء الضفه الغربيه الليله
الماضيه
تنضم الينا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري جيفارا اذا اقتحامات
بالجمله صباح هذا اليوم
عشيه الامس دعينا في التفاصيل وكيف هو
الوضع الان هل انتهت هذه الاقتحامات
الاقتحامات انتهت صباح هذا اليوم في بدايه
كان الاقتحام الاول كما ذكرتما لمخيم عسكر
القديم عندما دخلت قوات الاحتلال لاجراء
مسح هندسي لمنزل ابن او نجل الشهيد عبد
الفتاح خروشه بتهمه مساعدتي والده في
تنفيذ عمليه قبل شهرين في حواره في هذه
الاثناء اندلعت مواجهات مع الشبان
الفلسطينيين فسارعت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لاطلاق النار والرصاص الحي
بشكل عشوائي فاستشهد الشاب صالح صبرا
والبالغ من العمر 22 عاما في هذه الاثناء
يتم تشييع جثمانه الذي انطلق في موكبا
مهيبه من مستشفى رفيديا في مدينه نابلس
باتجاه وسط المدينه واقامه صلاه الجنازه
عليه عقب صلاه الظهر سينقل الجثمان ايضا
الشوارع الى مخيم بلاطه ومن ثم الى مخيم
عسكر القديم حيث مسقط راس الشهيد صبره في
هذه الاثناء ايضا كانت قوات الاحتلال
بدايه كوحده كوماندوز من المستعربين قد
اقتحمت مخيم طولكرم حاصلت المنزل بدعوى
اعتقال احد من تقول انهم مطلوبون لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه فور اكتشاف
امر هذه الوحده قام الشبان والاهالي
بمحاوله
المواجهه مع جنود الاحتلال الا ان قوات
الاحتلال قامت بدفع المزيد من التعزيزات
العسكريه الى داخل ومحيط المخيم اندلعت
مواجهات ولكن لم يصب احد
باذى ولم تتمكن ايضا قوات الاحتلال من
اعتقال هذا الشاب اعتقلت والده كنوع واضح
من الضغط على هذا المطارد لتسليم نفسه في
ذات الوقت كنا قد ذكرنا في مداخلات سابقه
ايضا الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال يخوضون
اليوم اضراب مفتوح عن الطعام ليوم واحد
كخطوه اولى ضمن الخطوات النضاليه بدايه
للمطالبه بالافراج الفوري عن الاسير وليد
الدقه الذي يعاني من وضع صحي خطير وامضى
اكثر من 37 عاما في سجون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انهاء سياسه العزل الانفرادي
وتحديدا التي يعاني منها الان امين عام
الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين الاسير احمد
السعادات في عزل السجن الجلمه وعدد من
رفاق وايضا الهجمه الشرسه على اسرى حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي والتاكيد على ان السلاح
الاضراب عن الطعام سيبقى مرفوعا خاصه بعد
استشهاد الاسير خضر عدنان الذي استشهد في
اليوم السابع والثمانين للاضراب عن الطعام
واكدت الحركه الاسيره في بيان سرب من داخل
السجون الاسرائيليه بان المقاومه
اقتحامات للضفه الغربيه لكن بعد وقفه
اطلاق النار هل زادت هذه الاقتحامات هل هي
على نفس الوتيره ام قلت
الاقتحامات
والانتهاكات لم تتوقف لم تتغير يعني منذ
صباح السبت حتى الان يعني في اقل من 48
ساعه قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اربعه
شهداء اثنان صباح السبت في مخيم بلاطه في
نابلس شهيد في مساء السبت في منطقه قضاء
جنين اليوم في نابلس في داخل مخيم عسكر
اذا اربعه شهداء في اقل من 48 ساعه ما
الذي تغير لا شيء قوات الاحتلال تواصل
انتهاكاتها هذا ايضا ما سيحمله الرئيس
الفلسطيني اليوم في رساله رسميه لاول مره
الامم المتحده تعقد جلسه خاصه لما اسمته
باحياء ذكرى انكبى الفلسطينيه لاول مره
بعد 75 عاما من النكبه الفلسطينيه التي
يحيي الفلسطينيون اليوم الذكرى هذه الذكرى
ستعقد جلسه خاصه للامم المتحده الرئيس
الفلسطيني
كلمه ما علمناها بان الرئيس سيؤكد في هذه
الكلمه على حجم الانتهاكات المتواصله ليس
باعداد يعني منذ 75 عاما ولكن حتى في هذا
العام العام الاخير عدد الشهداء الذين
سقطوا بتاكيد المؤسسات الدوليه والحقوقيه
حتى الدوليه منها بانها الاعلى دمويه
وايضا العام الماضي منذ اجتياح الضفه
الغربيه ما بين عام
2002 اذا نتحدث تقريبا فقط شيء اخير زين
بمعادله بسيطه كل يوم هناك شهيد اذا
الانتهاكات لم تتوقف رغم وقف اطلاق النار
بين غزه والاحتلال الاسرائيلي بين
المقاومه هناك والاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مراسله الجزيره من رام الله شكرا لك